I always tell people the secret to
writing is what they said what do you
think about don't think just let it come
through I didn't realize it at the time
but it was the greatest form of therapy
I ever had in my life because things
that I was feeling could actually be
expressed in lyrics I didn't know it was
a lyricist back then I was just kind of
discovering the whole process
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know with the Commodores late at
night in studio they just presented us
with a tour schedule of 366 page book
with 365 pages of exactly where we'll be
for the next year and I wrote a little
note down saying why would anybody put
chains on me I paid my dues to make it
everybody wants me to be what they want
me to be I'm not happy when I try to
when I fake it leave me alone so you
know you just walk in the door and just
hit those
[Music]
forget about it
after that the story is told I think
that was the first song that actually
gave me an opportunity to realize that I
could write a song and people would walk
up to you and go I feel the same way
perfect of all the songs that I thought
was going to be oh my god
this is not gonna work with Brickhouse I
don't know what's wrong with me but you
know all I kept thinking but I think it
was just the fear factor of I have to
play this song from my grandmother the
song came out and she didn't go to
church for about two or three weeks
because it was just absolutely
disgusting you know I'm saying and then
of course as the song became a hit she
kind of got over it because the check
came in everybody's happy
twice
we turn
I tried to write the funky song it came
out three times the lady people say to
me you left the conversation with your
parents and then you went over and wrote
the song no I heard what my dad said and
I walked away from the table and I said
that's a great thing he just said but it
has to go here into the universe and it
comes back around and when you're not
thinking about it at all it comes out it
happens when you just let go and let it
happen and of course three times the
lady was just as far left as I could
possibly imagine something would come
through but once it comes through my
biggest problem there now that I have it
I'm afraid of it so three times later
you have to understand in the middle of
funk here's a walls what am I gonna do
with a walls Eddie Levert was the one
who said to me you know you still have
time to take it back and put another one
out you know and at that particular time
it went straight to number one you know
because it was it was so disruptive and
so left of center that you know it was
James Carmichael the producer of the
Commodores who actually said that's the
moment
[Music]
now I have this song well my friends the
time has come to raise the roof and
hence more this great
Kurama fiesta forever come on and sing a
long come on and sing a long data the
data dead come on and sing I don't have
a hook and so I it took me probably
another month of just walking around my
house and everywhere trying to find out
what is the hook to come on and sing day
long I've got to give you the sing-along
so I went to one of my dear friends
houses I dr. Lloyd Greg and I went by
for dinner he's from Jamaica and I'm
leaving it now it's I took a break from
the studio I'm leaving his house now
about two o'clock in the morning and as
I'm leaving the house I'm saying to him
hey man I got to go back and work all
night long man all night long all night
long all night long
[Music]
a military commander in the field came
to me and I'm flying back from London he
said you know the story now I knew the
first half of the story the story was
that the people in Iraq wanted to
welcome the troops in and they wanted
them to know that they were welcome
within and it's friendly every shop
owner every store everything played all
night long on the speakers as they were
coming in here's the other half of that
story
the commander came to me and said do you
know what happened
with when we were coming into the city I
said no we wanted to tell them that we
were friendly so they played dancing on
the ceiling
on top of the Humvees coming into the
city and I said you gotta be kidding me
said no I just do we played dancing on
the ceiling and they were playing all
night long that's a true story we knew
and enjoyed his song all night long and
it kind of happened to fit our mission
as you could say the rest is history now
[Music]
this is what I had this is what I had
guys
[Music]
it's just hello is it me you're looking
for that's it
Carmichael he walks in hello is it me
you're looking for okay
all he had to do was say yes and
continue on
he said finish that song finished what
song he said you gotta finish the song I
said hello is it me you're looking for
it now I I've gotten away with sale on
three times a lady and I'm thinking now
by that time they've got me paranoid of
hokey I'm thinking hello is it me you're
looking for there throw me out of the
business if I try to do this and of
course I'm now writing the song to
finish it to make him happy
but I'm not thrilled about it
until I write the lyrics
now the lyrics the story fits perfectly
with the chord will change but it's now
in lush form we have more strings and
more orchestra on top of this I spent
the entire music video trying to explain
to Bob geraldi one thing first of all
his story was that the videos gonna be
shot with all these two people hugging
and kissing through the whole movie it's
gonna be great he walks in and says I'm
gonna make the girl blind you're gonna
do what I'm gonna make the girl blind
okay because I wanted Bob you're all -
he is the ticket in terms of videos back
in that time if you want Bob you're
always to do it and let him have his way
so we're not doing she's gonna be blind
and now I get to the set and the whole
thing is built on the fact that she's
now doing the the bus and I walk in and
as soon as I see the bus I'm going oh my
god we got a problem the bus does not
look like me so I'm now talking to Bob
when we're doing setup number one
Bob excuse me I just saw that bus it
doesn't look like me I know second setup
but before we get started have you seen
the bus it doesn't look like me
third fourth set up I'm now panicking
because the last set up is that scene so
I go pop and look like me
now it's time to do it so now I'm
looking at it I'm standing next to him
as if Bob doesn't look like me he looked
at me and said she's blind and I said oh
yeah there's a time in Europe I guess in
your creative discovery well you have to
ask the question where's it's coming
from Marvin Gaye one of my instructors
at the University of Motown you know
just said you can find out if you want
to but my suggestion is may you never
know where it comes from and he said
just let it go and keep receiving if you
get into the deepness of it it'll knock
you out you just have to think for a
moment keep moving forward write as fast
as you can get it get it from that side
to this side and then as time went on
one song to the next song you start
going okay I got this so as I got more
and more comfortable I could go to the
other side without trying to go to the
other side and you know now I the
problem is you want to stay over there
morning myself here and that's the
creative process you know when you can
just shut everything off on this side
because this is the now this is what's
happening but to go over there and trust
that you're you pick your songs
pick your notes pick everything
[Music]